a big shockwave both among staff and
continental European colleagues and
those based in the UK people are anxious
about what's going to happen my name is
awfully neither and I am professor of
plant development at the University of
Cambridge I'm coming up to London quite
often at the moment I currently chair
the Royal Society science policy
committee and we've been as a society
very engaged in putting forward the
voice of science in the brexit there are
three things that are really important
firstly freedom of movement for
scientists science is global it's really
important that scientists can come and
go
second thing it concerns funding so we
have benefited hugely from participating
in the European framework programs
the third thing is to do with
regulations your Atem for example which
concerns radioactive materials in in the
European Union it's very important again
that we we have some clarity on day one
the day we leave why we are such a
successful nation in science is because
of the way that we do science it's a
very open environment for science
it's very driven by kind of freedom of
ideas and expression we plant cells I
hope that that will be strong enough to
support us through this crisis and
continue to make the UK a really
attractive place to come it's it's that
kind of visceral anxiety that I think is
the major threat to the scientific
endeavor if that drives people apart
then that would be a tragedy